hi there reject nation I'm Greg I'm John
we're gonna watch the full trailer for
Swamp Thing on the DC Universe app you
know I am thinking of getting this app I
hear you can access like all the DC
comics and I've heard nothing but
amazing things about Doom Patrol and
Titans included actually and I've heard
it's definitely not going to be absorbed
into the Warner streaming service when
that happens yeah for some mix things on
the production of this so I'm very much
fascinated before we go into this thank
you to everyone who has been following
us over at our patreon page over there
we do weekly Q&A as well as TV show
reaction stream along for many shows
that includes attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man
Gotham John did all of hunting at Hill
House Cobra Kai season 2 and
Supernatural and several of those shows
have reaction highlights included those
are attack on Titan my hero academia
supernatural one punch man and Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
[Music]
[Music]
Atlantica the situation back in the
States
what Leonardo nah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all kinds of happens in this one
there's something special about this
place
[Laughter]
there's so much swampthing in that
trailer I know too many too many monster
shots don't show us the whole chair that
to keep it scary
I'm serious you can't show swampthing
all that much he's in it this whole damn
trailer him it looks like this could be
really cool really effective kind of a
blend of like an FX Network show meets a
little bit of an HBO vibe same time I
get a little worrisome that some of it
might be a little too campy or a little
too cheesy there's some elements that
felt very V there are times where it
felt intentional and there times where
it seemed like like the production
quality is kind of network TV a little
b-movie ish but not fully intentional at
times overall it looks creepy and fun I
don't really know Swamp Thing I like
this approach that we're kind of getting
with superhero genre lately of having a
lot more of a horror twist on it and
like that kind of grimy in the south
yeah yeah feels like really a key and
the creature effects and the designs of
a lot of those sequences do look really
unsettling very appealing to me that's
the most appealing part the acting in it
feels alright get something like really
cool character actors in here I've seen
pop-up in so many different things I'm
not entirely sure if this is gonna be
like cooler or just dumb yeah you go
either way for me here
I definitely feel you there I mean I'm
actually a pretty not that I've read a
million swampthing comics but I've been
aware of Swamp Thing over the years and
I'm really excited to see this character
come to the screen of any kind really
and I like to that they have at least
ostensibly for some of this a guy in the
suit it's Derek Mears playing Swamp
Thing who has done some great creature
work for predator and he was Jason and
the remake and stuff so the physicality
I can imagine is gonna be pretty cool
there if you have not only James Bond
but you have Gary Doberman from the
conjuring you know
getting behind the scenes on this so I
do like the overt horror aesthetic and
yeah that swampy nasty you've got these
like vines growing it's kind of kind of
reminded me of like a more freaky more
advanced version of a group type thing
the way he's like shooting out vines and
brains and stuff in those moments so is
this gonna be one of those things where
he's set up as a villain but then he's
really some kind of hero doesn't small
thing deal a lot with sort of like
mysticism this seems to be going like
just blood horror creature in the swamp
where I've heard that Swamp Thing kind
of deals a lot more than just primal
fear of creature and small oh yeah well
I know that there is at least a certain
ecological aspect and that Swamp Thing
kind of fights to protect the
environment to a degree idea that motive
here so yeah I don't I I don't know if
on this take or or in however many takes
because I know Alan Moore's written
swamp thing I know you know Swamp Thing
has been a relatively well tread to
character but I can definitely imagine
maybe an antihero kind of thing or maybe
yeah like a misunderstood sort of
Frankenstein monster sort of thing and
then eventually when people realize like
he just wants to protect the swamp end
by proxy the rest of nature
yeah maybe people will start to kind of
come around later through the season or
something I don't know
I'm wondering why they are choosing to
really kind of hide Swamp Thing in this
in the trailers though he's the title
character and it's Swamp Thing you know
like it I think for fans of Swamp Thing
they really wanna get some good looks at
him and yeah I would kind of like that
because some of the human characters
just seem a little wooden one this
trailer to me and to my you know site
anyway didn't really let much play out
it gave me a lot of quick moments and a
lot of cools
you know sizzle and things like that but
I don't really get a sense for what the
tone of an episode is gonna be like from
this I mean it looks kind of paranoid
but this makes it also look very fast
and very action II so I don't know I
mean if they're going for a horror angle
I can imagine that some breath and some
suspense is probably gonna be in there
but I honestly don't know and also it
worries me for the season is that they
did kind of unceremoniously cut it from
13 episodes to 10 which caught a lot of
the cast and crew by complete surprise
I don't know if this season's gonna be
feeling rushed overall because I don't
know I like that I didn't know that my
concern was the exact opposite which was
it's just gonna have that Marvel Netflix
Syndrome where it goes on too long or it
takes too long to build or it takes too
long to get to the [ __ ] point as you
know from here and there cutting it down
either that mean they eliminated
episodes it is trimmed out so much they
were able to condense it into ten
because if that's the case I'd be like
oh that's cool too here I hate when any
of these shows like goes on too long
yeah I'm with you in the sense that I
like 10 episodes more than 13 a lot of
the time from what I read anyway it
seemed like they were relatively deep
into shooting so it didn't come across
like oh we're gonna rearrange this make
it more compact cuz we don't need 13
episodes it seems sort of like we don't
really know what the future of our whole
operation is right now so we're just
gonna kind of kind of slow this thing
down I don't know it didn't seem at
least very clearly like this is gonna be
what's best for the story they look shot
really well great spooky angles and here
throughout and the lighting here you
could feel that real sort of sombering
ray I could feel the weather you know
yeah feel the atmosphere I like the
paranoia of the town's disease outbreak
yeah I guess I'm just more fascinated by
what is the actual tone gonna be because
it seems to go really straight and some
of the performances seem to have this
heightened level of camp
well that tone mesh well with what the
performers are doing because all the
performers all around seem to kind of be
going for the same level but the
trailers emotion is not communicating
camp I just want to know what the vibe
is sometimes a show trailer is kind of
tricky because you got a show a bunch of
previews of your whole season I hope it
gets violent hoping it's like hard are I
would love I would love for this to get
like very gory yeah that'd be really
relate some twisted ashes that's what
I'm hoping for and I wonder if maybe
they're just you know it's keeping Swamp
Thing sparse to get people to tune in
you know well guys are you excited for
Swamp Thing do you have the DC streaming
service app I know that all you guys in
India do before I wrap this up I want to
shout out a guy who definitely lives in
a swamp his name is Andrew
opening number Andrew I remember it's
been on this channel before the guy has
his own YouTube channel there's a link
in the description box for it he does
some really good gaming videos he sent
us over links of rainbow succeed
wonderful wonderful Let's Plays he
recently got engaged he's set to get
married I'm happy for you buddy that's
but always no need to be a hopeless
romantic I hope you can drown her in a
swamp and you could die there to see you
guys could live on together in the
afterlife haunting people down in the
south of Texas were through swamps I
don't know what Texas is like either way
man I hope that you're having a great
time than that you impregnate her as
soon as possible because that's a great
way to make sure she stays in your life
for the remainder no matter what goes
down Garrett guaranteed you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and if you like
this video hit the like button check you
guys out soon